sepia DreamWorks in Universal logos
helpfully prepare you for the most
yellow tinted movie ever made 35 seconds
of reading 28 seconds of wheat enjoying
how did this horse know where to go with
a headless horseman on top of it at my
signal unleash hell what you mean the
dog three weeks from now I will be
harvesting my crops imagine where you
will be and it will be so so I guess all
the guys who died in this battle are
imagining themselves in the ground right
about now
well you are in Elysium you already dad
2013 movie with the same name retro
actively makes this hilarious wildling
army just stands there and screams for
minutes on end while the roman army
makes ready for battle and the enemy
army pays for their inaction by taking a
vicious beating once the roman army gets
all set up and everything
oh I see that hans zimmer rewarmed this
score for the pirates of the carribean
later that's not so much a sin for this
movie but hey When in Rome you don't
care who's who you don't care who the
Romans are fighting all you care about
is the fact that this is a generic
battle opening and you put too much salt
on your King popcorn fortunate
passers-by fire battle shaky-cam
I shall sacrifice a hundred wolves to
honor your triumph save the wolves just
get some whiskey for my men and some
beer for my horses washing your bloody
hands in the dirty blood water of
previous washers I realized they had
limited options but are thousands of
candles the best way to go about
lighting the interior of a cloth tent
would you be able to make do with less
than half the open flames you have going
in this thing right now
if only you had been born a man what a
Caesar you would have made the way
things were back then
why does Joaquin Phoenix remind me so
much of rufus sewell in this movie do
you remember rufus sewell the ninety
sure do this came out in 2000 just after
the rufus sewell was always the bad guy
era was coming to a close you accept
this great honor that I have offered you
with all my heart
no Maximus is a dick to original
Dumbledore and Commodus Commodus is not
a moral man Commodus cannot rule he rule
yeah well what this movie sweeps under
the rug is how many times the real
Marcus oh really escaped more and more
power to Commodus as he approached his
death so why would you give it a moral
man all that power man I'm gonna well
except by decision unlikely the surgeons
say there was no pain
excuse me to whom did you just refer to
your medical practitioners as surgeons a
word that was not invented for more than
a thousand years from now the emperor
has been slayed okay so we know Maximus
is right and it's okay to have
suspicions but he has zero proof does he
know what era he lives in right until
dawn and then executes what why dawn why
not until you get tired or until the
blood moon rises over the harvest sky
arbitrary reason to make Maximus his
execution take place far away so he can
escape as arbiter Caesar sends four
regular dudes to kill the best warrior
Rome has ever seen looks definitely
passed on here
since you know sunbeams so why haven't
they killed him yet at least give me a
clean death soldiers death they fall for
this grabbing a sword this way should
cause major injuries especially when
swinging it in a violent manner
oh lucky a shot sudden picturesque
lightning meanwhile on the moon
sure let's carve out a horsey circle in
our actual crops as opposed to doing
this on any of the regular old land we
have how did these guys even know where
they were going I don't know maybe
someone in the army had visited there
before but we're talking nearly three
years since Maximus himself had been
there and this journey they just made is
over a thousand miles it's not like
someone can go travel to Spain and then
a right at the McDonald's and then
you're at his house what did he just now
realize that his family was in danger
for no good reason horse decides to stop
running and be a dick right here and now
movie rips off the hero finds his loved
ones as charred corpses thing from Star
Wars ah I see the soldiers were ordered
to not only kill Maximus his family but
display them like this so in case he
escaped his execution he'd be extra sad
about their deaths grief drool movie
suddenly turns into requiem for a drink
don't die they'll feed you to the Lions
but when I care if I'm already dead how
much you want to bet the owner suckered
the town's folk into paying for this
arena
you sold me queer offs that's racist
Augie - mm I'm full for the beasts
that's 5000 for an old friend um it is
if you were going to give yourself a
discount why didn't you just say I'll
give you 3,000 for the Beast you know
since you're the one dictating the terms
anyway queer giraffes
well the vulture symbolism is a little
heavy-handed I got to admit guy who made
a show of telling these guys they were
all worthless and we're going to die
soon back when he bought them is now
giving them a pep talk to try and get
them to fight well one speech does not
jive with the other speeches all I'm
saying he running down someone's leg to
show scaredy cat miss cliche here is
even more confusing battle scenes even
though there are far less combatants you
guys just tell me when the main
characters win I'm gonna nod off for a
second the gladiating will go down
exactly like this Rome doesn't have
quite the Buzzard problem of the other
arena we saw earlier rated T for teen
one of the rules of this stuff do the
opponents have to watch Maximus fight
one-on-one battles or could they join in
on the fight and make it a lot less fair
are you not a somewhat
well we hated you until you yelled at us
about being entertained so yeah we like
you now the great who was suck a listen
to we're fat and happy and can suckle no
more wait I thought it was the more
doing the suckling how do you get fat
and happy when the whore suckles you ups
you will have your freedom set the guy
who could literally give him freedom
right now if he really wanted to ie his
owner thunder and lightning indicates
something ominous cliche in kiss incest
request I get the detention room and
there aren't newspaper photos of Maximus
on microfiche at the local library but
to ask me to buy that he went all this
way through all these smaller fights and
provinces and not one single former
soldier has ever recognized him that's
unpossible also let's let the heir to
the Roman throne hang out inches from
killer barbarian warrior slaves what's
the worst that could happen I don't have
been in the Army but I serve we go
Vindobona funny that that didn't come up
until now that guy Nazi Juba running
towards it fries ah
Maximus only decides not to kill
Commodus because of a kid my name is
Maximus Decimus Meridius I should have
known something was up but none of the
soldiers I sent to kill you return and I
will have my vengeance in this life or
the next
love those words this life is your only
option though I mean surely in the next
life you'll forget all about it
but good luck they lied to me in
Germania they told you he was dead they
what they nobody returned from the
execution to confirm his death this man
wants what you no one hears that I mean
later he says God the lady has finished
with me so there's someone within
earshot hearing all this conspiracy
early Roman concessions practices
okay so last fight all of Rome found out
this was Maximus main General of the
Roman army yet he's somehow still a
slave gladiator how's the no public
outcry about how he became a slave in
the first place how are there not riots
to set him free how was this next
gladiator match happening now maybe he
they heard he spoke out against Commodus
but he's incredibly unpopular anyway so
what the fuck Maximus doesn't take
advantage of this guy turning his head
patricide wait a minute wasn't Quintus
responsible for sending Maximus to his
death and Commodus was upset that they
lied to him about Maximus being dead so
why is Quintus able to sit here in the
VIP box and not dead well I guess if one
random asshole says it then the whole
crowd can get on board with that also
how does one asshole get his voice heard
in the middle of an arena with all that
noise going on Maximus is a lucky fuck
they tell me your son squealed like a
girl when they nailed him to the cross
yes but as Maximus probably knows
Commodus his soldiers are pretty
unreliable when it comes to things that
actually happen I may find me is it
difficult to find the prisoner slay of
gladiators in their cells no matter how
hot your sister is this should probably
be filed under the to gross to attempt
portion of your brain much too late an
unbelievable love story comes out of
nowhere because somebody's got to get a
little action in this movie that's
cheating on the dead wife that you're
going to see soon right
Caesars nephew is a dick to Caesar save
her from a 2sat that the answer to this
question requires secrecy to the
audience also seriously Lucilla is going
around saying this in front of her kid
changes one new freedom so Oliver Reed
died during filming but necessary or not
at CGI shot of him is from Erie that is
enough okay so this shot definitely came
from that seen earlier when Maximus was
yelling about Commodus hang up
everything you didn't think we'd
remember did you instead of killing
Maximus for trying to escape sure let's
just arrest him again and keep making
him gladiator himself how are all these
assholes throwing rose petals any kind
of distance in the Colosseum that
general became a slave slave who became
a gladiator the gladiator defy to nefra
sounds like a good thing to put on the
poster and/or trailer striking story
movie takes the time to pad itself on
the back stop on his armor conceal the
wound this guy's still alive but that'd
be a listen to you 15 and 16 years ago
but lots of roses in your movie and it
wins Best Picture
movie rips off to see the people you
love after your die thing from Titanic
damn death is so amazingly close to life
he should have done this earlier it's
rum with one good
lands like well an epic movie winds to a
close time for a ponderous speech
symbolism by signal unleash hell
who so pulleth out this sword of this
stone and anvil is rightwise king born
of England nail need before so you will
never find the more wretched hive of
scum and villainy if I can change
because his means and you can change
we're more fifties minute sir would you
change
a German boy go back to Germania my
father favors you now my lady many
things change some things never changed
Jason some things do and like walls it
was good the first day and then the
formless light began to take on
substance shit second down they all say
that until weather
Disgaea they tell me your son squealed
like a girl screaming like a stuck Irish
Pig